mesdames et messieurs bonsoir la
température en france continue à être
très douce et j'espère que vous avez
passé un bon week notre page
international est chargé deux événements
principaux primo le sac et l' incendie
de l'ambassade des états unis en libye
et secundo le départ inattendu aussitôt
du shah d'iran qui a quitté l'hôpital où
il se trouvait à new york pour être
conduit dans un hôpital militaire au
texas les informations sur ce départ ont
plusieurs fois varié au cours de la
journée
notre représentant permanent washington
jack séguy nous dit où en sont les
choses dès que le départ du shah de new
york a été connue les étudiants
islamiques ont réagi à téhéran son
départ des etats-unis ont-ils annoncé
précipiterait l'ouverture du procès des
otages ce procès ne sera peut-être pas
immédiat mais nous allons accélérer au
maximum les préparatifs alors deuxième
sujet disions-nous de vives
préoccupations prises états unis la mise
à sac et l' incendie de l'ambassade
américaine en libye à tripoli
cela survient un mois après les
événements à leur ambassade de teyran et
dix jours après l'un sans vie de leur
ambassade au pakistan il n'y avait qu'un
seul policier de garde devant
l'ambassade des états unis ce qui a
évidemment facilité la tâche des
manifestants mise à sac et incendies
mais pas de victime
étrange tout de même cette attaque de
l'ambassade des états unis car le
président kadhafi a appelé hier à la
modération l'iran et demandé la
libération des otages
alors pourquoi sans doute pour marquer
une solidarité à l'égard de l'iran de la
révolution iranienne et également de
khomeiny car entre kadhafi et khomeiny
il ya incontestablement des points
communs car la libye veut également être
le porte drapeau d'un islam dur en fait
le monde islamique est en ébullition ici
et là et même les amis de l'occident
taux 10 ans les modérés du monde arabe
comme l'arabie saoudite ne sont pas à
l'abri ainsi à la mosquée de la mecque
et contrairement à ce que l'on avait
annoncé tous ces jours derniers les
choses ne sont pas terminées absolument
et 12 jours après cette attaque on
continue à se battre dans les sous-sols
de la mecque l'armée saoudienne utilise
des gaz lacrymogènes mais les insurgés
sont bien organisés et résiste il y a
dit aux deux cent soixante-dix pièces
sous cette mosquée qui est en fait une
véritable ville et leurs chances sont
pratiquement nulles de s'en sortir mais
quand même avec leurs actions ils ont
mis en danger la dynastie saoudienne
et si jamais cette dynastie saoudienne
tomber si le régime actuel de l'arabie
saoudite tomber cela pourrait poser des
problèmes beaucoup plus grave peut-être
que l'iran car deux tiers du pétrole des
occidentaux vient justement de l'arabie
saoudite
il semble donc qu autour de la peur mais
ils se produisent une certaine
déstabilisation du monde islamique
incontestablement promet ni a été le
détonateur du monde islamique
il y à des sympathisants de l'ayatollah
khomeini partout dans le monde dans le
monde islamique
grâce à son pouvoir charismatique et
beaucoup vous devez suivre son exemple
ce pouvoir de l'ayatollah on le voit
très bien en iran où l'on votait pour la
nouvelle constitution islamique
aujourd'hui l'ayatollah a voté dans sa
ville de coos et partisans étaient
déchaînés un véritable débordement de
passion
à téhéran les iraniens ont voté plus
calmement un bulletin vert pour le oui à
la constitution un rouge pour le nom
mais pas d'isoloir pour choisir et
autour des bureaux de vote des gardiens
de la révolution en armes
la nouvelle constitution a donc toutes
les chances d'être adoptée à une
majorité écrasante ce sera un pay by
side pour l'ayatollah quelques incidents
secondes dans plusieurs villes et dans
plusieurs régions où les opposants ont
appelé à un boycott des bureaux de là
dans ce projet de nouvelle constitution
les femmes paraissent plutôt d'oublier
aucun article en effet ne traite de
leurs droits civils notamment dans le
mariage n'est dans le divorce
encore que le préambule de la
constitution proposée précise que les
femmes cesseront d'être uniquement
l'objet des plaisirs sexuels de l'homme
que pensent les femmes iraniennes de
cette constitution
la prière des femmes
chaque vendredi à l'université de
téhéran la condition sociale des
iraniennes apparaît ici au grand jour
les femmes de condition modeste comme
celles qui viennent ici sont voilées et
séparées des hommes afin d'écarter toute
tentation
à l'heure où l'on prie dieu
la plupart de ces femmes portaient en
fait déjà le voile du temps du régime
impérial
elle avait même lutté pour le garder car
du jour au lendemain on leur avait
demandé de ne plus cacher leurs visages
soumise à un milieu social où la femme
doit être voilées et n'ont pas
conscience d'une aliénation quelconque
la révolution l'avènement de la
république islamique a donc été pour
elle une sorte de libération qui
prétendait assurer la protection de la
femme à travers le voile au nom de dieu
dans l'islam
je me sens libre même avec mon tchador
pour moi ça n'est pas une contrainte
c'est un élément de fierté je peux
combattre
même avec ce voile quant à la
constitution islamique
j'estime qu'elles redonnent une dignité
à la femme iranienne le prestige du
voile apparaît même chez l'enfant dans
ce milieu où la religion dicte la
conduite quotidienne
le tchador est devenu un vêtement de
fierté et de dignité qui doit inspirer
le respect mais pour les femmes qui
peuvent comparer avec la condition
féminine dans d'autres pays du monde
ce régime qui oblige à cacher son visage
est non seulement rétrograde mais même
contraire à l'islam
ce sont tous des réactionnaires
et le labri lebris là c'est l'islam des
femmes que vous avez vues dans les rues
l'islam qui montre que la femme et le
prend la première dans les révolutions
les femmes qui sont dans la maison dans
leur travail et dans la société
tous les trois est une révolutionnaire
le juge estime ainsi que votre liberté
est aliéné ou pas pour tout le monde
ça manque de liberté avant le référendum
sur la constitution islamique
les mouvements de femmes des étudiantes
pour la plupart se sont réunis dans la
semi-clandestinité dans les sous sols de
l'université de téhéran les étudiants
islamiques avaient coupé l'électricité
pour les empêcher de tenir cette réunion
et c'est à la lueur des bougies qu'elles
ont dit non à la nouvelle constitution
non parce qu'elle ne donne pas les mêmes
droits aux femmes qu'aux hommes
non parce que la loi islamique relègue
la femme au foyer
non parce que le nouveau régime à créer
des tribunaux spéciaux pour les juger et
qu'elles peuvent être mariés de force
dès l'âge de 13 ans bien que le régime
islamique cherche à étouffer les
mouvements de femmes
les iraniennes n'hésite pas à continuer
de descendre dans la rue manifester
comme ici contre la politique américaine
aux côtés des hommes la constitution le
reconnaît le droit de vote dès l'âge de
16 ans
cette largesse peut surprendre mais les
religieux au pouvoir savent que les
opposants au régime islamique ne sont
qu'une minorité et que le fait de
laisser voter les femmes consolide au
contraire leur appui populaire à paris
invité du club de la presse d'europe
numéro h pot de la baie le président du
groupe rpr à l'assemblée s'est dit
profondément troublé par les
déclarations du chef de l'état sur
antenne 2 marques y prétendre dit
monsieur l'abbé que les français seront
1% dans le monde à la fin du siècle et
qu'ils devront adapter la politique à ce
niveau là c'est la négation du gaullisme
voilà ce qu'il a dit et d'autre part il
a confirmé qu'il irait bien un candidat
rpr aux présidentielles congrès à paris
du mouvement démocrate socialiste l'une
des composantes de l'udf et que préside
monsieur max lejeune un congrès dominé
par la perspective des présidentielles
pour monsieur jean lecanuet président
d'edf il faut déplacer la kz2 la
majorité si monsieur giscard d'estaing
l'emportant 81 dit monsieur de canut et
les déchirements du parti socialiste
alimenteront le socialisme de la raison
aux dépens du socialisme de l'illusion
et de la fiction fantastique
dans l'hebdomadaire le point un sondage
toujours à propos des présidentielles
premières constatations c'est monsieur
rocard qui paraît le mieux placé selon
42% des personnes interrogées pour
conduire l'opposition au second tour et
ce mitterrand ne vient qu'ensuite avec
31% des réflexes
deuxième constatation le bilan de
l'action du président de la république
est jugée par 42% des français plutôt
non satisfaisants et par 39% plutôt
satisfaisant troisième constatation les
intentions de vote au second tour donne
monsieur giscard d'estaing vainqueur de
tous ses adversaires possibles
c'est monsieur rocard qui résisterait le
mieux mais monsieur giscard d'estaing
l'emporterait quand même avec 53 %
contre 47 à monsieur roch en ce dimanche
7 millions d'électeurs portugais ont
voté dans le calme et sous un chaud
soleil afin d'élire un parlement pour
huit mois jusqu'à la fin normal de la
législature en cours car l'assemblée
sortante avait été dissoute par le
président et anne heche en septembre le
voici qui vient à voter le gouvernement
actuel onzième depuis la révolution et
qui est dirigé par madame de lurdes
pinta s'il go avait obtenu l'appui des
partis de gauche pour gérer le pays en a
commencé élections d'aujourd'hui
selon le président et anne heche quels
que soient les résultats des élections
ils seront intégralement accepté et
respecté n'oublions pas que le président
est aussi le chef d'état major général
de la alors parmi les enjeux de ces
élections il ya un point qui divise la
gauche et la droite et qui a été discuté
avec passion pendant toute la campagne
électorale la réforme agraire notamment
dans le sud du portugal
la région de la dante jo un reportage
d'emmanuel cardozo à gauche et président
de la coopérative val nombre et deux
hommes sont morts le 28 septembre
dernier deux paysans abattu par la
police qui accompagnait l'ancien
propriétaire venu reprendre ses terres
des terres qu'ils avaient été distribués
aux paysans par la réforme agraire et
que la loi lui a rendu photos à l'appui
il raconte les faits à joseph le paysan
que les coopérateurs nous ont donné
comme guide et qui parle un peu le
français joseph traduit nous a expulsé
deux noté
et alors que faites-vous ben on peut
rien contre les fusains mais sitôt les
soldats partis nous récupérons la terre
lancement sont là cultivons s'ils
viennent nous partons s'ils partent nous
revenons joseph nous a accompagné sa
coopérative aval aux bruits dans tout le
portugal il y en a environ 500 qui comme
celles ci font vivre chacune de trois à
six cents personnes de grandes
propriétés de douze mille hectares et
plus en friche et que les paysans
avaient récupéré lors de la révolution
en 74 la loi a officialisé la situation
mais le gouvernement socialiste de mario
soares a modifié la réforme agraire en
restituant une partie des terres à leur
ancien propriétaire dans cette grande
province de la lente et jo le parti
communiste règne en maître
une province où les arabes ont laissé
leur empreinte notamment dans le costume
des femmes mais aussi dans ses chansons
spontanée où on peut tout raconter les
joies les peines et même la politique
des capitalistes fallait saluer chapeau
bas dit joseph et quand on veut les voir
qu'on leur demandait bonjour notre
maître ès qui aurait du travail pour moi
il répondait est plus important il dit
christian ils voulaient du travail
non je n'ai pas de travail j'ai passé
six communes c'est mieux econiche
toujours pensé les ouvriers toujours
pensé qui s'écrivait fin que je pense
est organisé et quelque chose pour les
plus manger mieux pour la vie et de
travail et pas les autres et les autres
et les autres partis il est social
démocratie c'est pas bon après la mort
des deux hommes tués aval l'ombre et le
parti a procédé à une mobilisation
générale des coopérateurs monsieur
cunhal secrétaire-général du pc
portugais est allé voir le premier
ministre linda sieg haut pour lui dire
si les restitutions de terre continue je
ne réponds plus de rien
pita si legault a tout arrêté en
attendant les prochaines élections
on ne sait pas de quoi serait capable
ses hommes pour défendre leur terre
ainsi manuel cardozo le jour où nous
l'avons rencontré
il nous a emmenés sur les lieux où était
mort ses camarades
la maison du propriétaire était à côté
et l'homme n'a pas pu résister comme
attiré par un aimant il a filé droit
vers la grande maison de maître dont les
volets étaient déjà fermés et le
propriétaire reparti et puis tout à coup
sans que nous lui ayons rien demandé il
nous a dit voyez quand on est arrivé ici
l'herbe était haute et tout était à
l'abandon nous avons travaillé on a fait
200 hectares de bonnes terres à blé
cette terre est à nous et pas à ceux qui
sont partis qui avons travaillé et parmi
les travailleurs
je peux vous assurer qu'il y en a qui
sont tous prêts à prendre des fusil et a
tiré sur ceux qui voudraient leur
reprendre cette terre le maroc ne
participera pas à la réunion du comité
des sages de l'organisation de l'unité
africaine oua qui doit se tenir mardi et
mercredi à monrovia pour examiner la
question du sahara occidental selon
monsieur m'hamed boucetta ministre
marocain des affaires étrangères
la raison de la décision marocaine et la
partialité dont font preuve certains
pays à l'encontre des intérêts du masque
revenons en france notre sympathique
confrères marie-claire fête ses 25 ans
d'âge la caméra de jacques delarue s'est
promené sur la belle collection de
photographies entre autres de mode que
ça représente un commentaire de jean
jacques dufour
non
les années 50
brillante années d'après guerre où l'on
retrouve les soucis de la futilité la
mode parisienne a repris sa suprématie
mondiale les femmes corsetée entraves et
de bijoux de gants de châtrés subissent
avec joie les lois implacables de la
haute couture de christian dior d'envoi
des grands couturiers
on ne parle pas encore de prêt à porter
il y a que le grand couturier et la
petite couturière
une mode qui soit dit en passant vous
donne 10 ans de plus d'un seul tailleur
c'est l'époque de la femme épouse
soumise qui s'habille pour séduire
l'homme capable de lui fabriquer une
belle vie des hommes qui préfèrent les
blondes on guette dans l'actualité rose
de marie claire les jeunes premiers du
moment le fiancé photographe de margaret
la rebelle gérard philipe jacques
charrier une brune heures louis jourdan
françois périer et cetera des couples
célèbres se forment à licques ans et
rita hayworth brigitte bardot qui arrive
qu'on vole avec vadim dieu créa la femme
une femme que symbolise au début de ces
années 50
audrey hepburn resplendissante mais déjà
sournoise la lutte pour l'émancipation
commence françoise sagan écrit à 19 ans
et en 31 jours bonjour tristesse cheveux
courts au vent la condition féminine
prend les chemins de sa liberté
les années 60 ce sont les années d'
enthousiasme où l'on croit sincèrement
que tout va changer on débarque sur la
lune
on vit dans le graphisme et le design le
corps des femmes est libre dans une mode
très construite courrèges raccourci les
jupes libère les genoux et jette les
soutiens gorge aux orties la petite robe
blanche succède au niveau de la petite
robe noire parler de contraception et le
planning familial et déjà l'audace des
femmes les plus évolués
s'ils sont réticents sur le fond les
jeunes acceptent des yeux l'émancipation
car sur le chemin des années 60 on
découvre les genoux de toutes les d'un
inconnu dans la rue célèbre dans les
revues raquel welch brigitte bardot
encore et toujours elle sylvie vartan
shirley mclaine avec maurice chevalier
ces jeux nous changerons il la passe du
monde en tout cas certains hommes comme
andré maurois s'inquiète ce qui me
trouble le plus ce sont les expériences
près matrimoniale des jeunes filles gens
redoutent que cela s'établissent dans
nos moeurs au même moment la callas et
mona this faudrait byrne est listé leurs
demandes 500 million par film
catherine deneuve est belle mais c'est
le début de la fin des monstres sacrés
racing de rivoyre déclare nous ne sommes
pas toutes courtisane ou ménageait les
phallocrates tremble l'année de la femme
se rapproche les années 70 la liberté
des femmes passent par toutes les
revendications d'égalité avec les hommes
mais concrètes se font rapide pas assez
encore au goût de certaines et ce sont
les années du vêtement sauvage de la
mode paul klee de la mode rétro en 1979
yves saint laurent propose une
silhouette noire et suse séduisante et
hyper féminine
pourtant au début de ces années on
retrouvera beaucoup de banderoles et de
militantes année du procès de bobigny du
mlf gisèle halimi avocate des femmes est
sur tous les fronts tandis que deux
vedettes de cinéma
jane fonda et delphine seyrig s'engage à
fond dans le militantisme simone veil
est nommé ministre de la santé
françois giroux secrétaire d'état à la
condition féminine
on arrive ainsi à l'année de la femme de
la loi veil sur l'avortement
ainsi soit elle écrit benoîte groult
ainsi soit elle les irlandaises qui
milite pour la paix
les femmes qui deviennent chefs de
gouvernement et les anti star qui sonne
le glas d'une époque
isabelle huppert miou miou bernadette
lafont isabelle adjani en trop preuve
que les temps ont changé on ne respecte
même plus brigitte bardot qui est
toujours là dans son numéro de novembre
hara kiri la reproduit avec un rictus
découvrant une seule et unique incisive
légende il y a 20 ans j'avais toutes mes
dents demain ce lundi à 20h35 aussitôt
après le journal ce sera démission de
jean-pierre elkabbach numério question
d'un thème demain qui passionnera tous
les amateurs de cinéma à woody allen qui
est l'homme qui est le comédien qui est
l'auteur franz roche vous présentera
woody allen
actuellement l'acteur comique le plus
populaire aux états unis et pas
seulement là bas si j'en juge ou
recettes que font ces films en europe
demain donc à 20h35 une émission que les
amateurs de cinéma et les autres ne
manqueront pas à auteuil victoire en est
d'un très bon cheval favino qui a rendu
du poids tout le monde est dans le
tiercé un steeple chase pour poulains et
pouliches de 4 ans une surprise avec la
victoire de tomber la laub cder de
pierrette brès laquelle a donné hier
soir le tiercé dans le désordre meirieu
est très disputé un résultat indécis
jusqu'au bout
voici le dernier kilomètre de la course
de ces tirs s'est créé france soir
dimanche les chevaux sort du dernier
tournant mis tout cas qui a mené la
course de bout en bout est toujours en
tête du peloton pour sauter la double
barrière
très près d'elle manfred commence à
prendre l'aventage ils sont suivis de
bus hyérois de toul quand bella cabaret
tente à 1000 tout cas qui a tracé un
parcours remarquable continue son effort
mais man frais est à ses côtés pour
sauter la dernière e et pendant que
quand bella lance maintenant son attaque
ortika casaque verte et blanche qui a
attendu un peu trop sagement en queue de
peloton fait maintenant une remontée
fort de l'air à l'extérieur misto cas
luttent toujours contre nomme frais mais
elle commence à pencher à gauche c'est
un signe de fatigue
miss tout cas pour lui quatre fois en un
mois elle a donné son maximum
quand vela l'outsider son voyant la
victoire pendant que man frais registre
attaque perdu d'ortie six cas c'est une
belle arrivée très groupée 11 6 4 et
bien voilà sur les écrans des rapports
du tiercé rugby à montauban la france a
battu la roumanie un adversaire
difficile par 30 12
un score qui permet de penser qu'à un
mois du tournoi des six nations le
quinze de jean pierre rives est en
excellente forme
quelques extraits du match avant de vous
parler de tennis de table et de la
rencontre internationale d'evry dominé
par les pongistes chinois d'abord rugby
la deuxième mi-temps vient de commencer
les français sont menés 9 à 3 3
pénalités à une et c'est à ce moment là
que l'équipe de france fait son pressing
pour finalement envoyer à l'essai
cordoniou égalité 9-9 entre les deux
équipes car jean-michel aguirre réussi
la transformation
ce n'est pas fini pour des français
décidément retrouver qui dans cette fin
de match on faire un admirable forcing
voilà on joue une pénalité à la main
on essaie d'enfoncer le pack roumain la
balle va sortir côté français et gally
entendent tout seul de marquer l'essai
il est projeté en touche par les
roumains qui joue rapidement cette
touche balle contrôlé par la france
galop ouvre caussade pour bertranne qui
sert à guer intercalé lequel fons essaie
de prendre des fois la défense roumaine
se fait plaquer à un mètre de la ligne
le ballon n'est pas enterrée par les
français attention monsieur d'intrants
faut pas prendre un adversaire pour un
paillasson on siffle une mêlée
la mêlée est rapidement joué par la
france elle va sortir
gardez d'abord en troisième ligne par
les tricolores elle va finalement sortir
par jean pierre rives qui sert galion
puis sur le petit côté on essaie de
passer là aussi encore les roumains qui
provoque une mêlée et cette fois ci on
ouvre de l'autre côté grand côté si vous
permettez l'expression avec encore une
attaque de jean michel aguirre intercalé
qui veut servir bertranne voici vertal
récupère ce ballon feinte la passe et
finalement passe en force pour marquer
l'essai entre les poteaux un essai qui
donne l'avantagé à la france 21 à 12
devant la roumanie car aggir à
transformer cet essai est à la dernière
minute de jeu c'est jouannel qui marque
encore un troisième essai pour la france
2 dans la victoire au français 30 à 12
devant la roumanie domination totale de
la chine populaire aux internationaux de
france de tennis de table à evry en
simple messieurs en finale ici deux
sociétaires de la chine populaire wang
chun ex à issac le style est à peu près
le même pas tout à fait cependant l'un
des deux joueurs utilisent la prise
porte plume pratique pourtant
pratiquement disparu depuis la
révolution culturelle il fallait tout
mettre en oeuvre pour battre et
européens
et tenez vous bien ces chinois ici
présents ne figure même pas parmi les
meilleurs mondiaux du souci à se faire
donc dans l'avenir
côté européen
l'automne lamartine gizeh dans ses
méditations salut bois couronné d'un
reste de verdure feuillage jaunit 100
sur les gazons et par salut derniers
beaux jours le deuil de la nature
convient à la douleur est plein et
regards normalement au début de décembre
les derniers beaux jours sont déjà
passés mais cet automne 79 n'est pas
comme les autres il est très doux et en
forêt de brocéliande l'une des forêts
les chevaliers de la table ronde
la promenade est encore bien agréable
à
aucune forêt des banales à l'automne
mais ces six mois que tous tentent parce
que la plupart des aventures des
chevaliers de la table ronde se seraient
déroulés sur ces sentiers sous ses
frondaisons dans leur fameuse quête du
graal la recherche du massacre et dans
lequel joseph d'arimathie avait
recueilli le sang du christ mourant sur
la croix
dans leur quête du graal donc ils
connurent ses chevaliers en armure matt
péripéties mad épreuve qui les faisait
passer par ce val sans retour ou la
méchante morgan enchaîné certains par
les charmes très terre à terre
suivre la trace de galade et de l'an
flot dans les fougères
tomber au détour d'un chemin sur la
fontaine de barenton ou le plus grand
des magiciens et des barres de
l'armorique l'enchanteur merlin se vit
soutirait tous ses pouvoirs par la fée
viviane qu'il aimait et vice versa
voici donc la forêt de brocéliande
chargé de sortilège qui font bon ménage
avec la fois puisqu'on les retrouve
jusque dans les peintures les vitraux et
les mosaïques de la minuscule église de
tréhorenteuc ou le profane et le sacré
font bon ménage
à l'ombre des clochers la récupération
du païen donne parfois de ces petits
chefs-d'oeuvre
il pleut sur procès liant d' sous ce
ciel vénéneux la légende oscille entre
le romantisme et le drame entre eux la
flûte enchantée les cuivres de wagner
il pleut sur brocéliande et qui quêtent
il promeneurs le saint graal
bon et si ce graal c'était seulement un
petit morceau un petit moment
d'enchantement demain persistance du
beau temps sur le quart sud est du pays
dans le sud ouest des brouillards
matinaux seront suivies de quelques
passages nuageux sur la moitié nord de
la france
temps assez nuageux avec quelques
faibles pluies ou bruines surtout de la
bretagne à la normandie à la région
parisienne et honore les vents d'ouest à
sud ouest se renforcera notre édition
est terminée et vers 23 heures c'est par
ammar qui vous donnera les dernières
informations de la journée demain
antennes 2010 vous sera présentée par
patrick lecocq et amateurs vous
retrouverez ici même patrick poivre
d'arvor
bonsoir merci